When I give 10 pounds in charity and it
is consumed, the rewards come to an end.
However, if I give to a waqf, then
you've put your money into something
permanent, which means a endowment that
continues to give on your behalf until
the day you meet Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala. Subhanallah, that is amazing.
Here at Iman Legacy Builders, we want
you to build a legacy with your sadaqah.
Where will your donation be going?
Events. Global events inspiring the iman
of millions around the world. Education.
Free Quran lessons, free lectures, free
reminders. Number three, media. Content
for kids, educational shows, spiritual
Islamic shows. Online, brothers and
sisters, go to the link inshallah and
donate in these blessed 10 days
inshallah. May Allah bless you guys.
Assalamualaikum Wa Rahmatullahi Wa
Barakatuh. So, the breaking news
brothers and sisters, the latest
breaking news that's coming inshallah is
that Israel, the genocidal mini state,
the only democracy in the Middle East,
uh has who's been massacring children,
50,000 plus, etc., who have known for
killing men, women, and children. And
they said they were going to attack um
ministry infrastructure, has attacked
the Iranian national TV station. This is
um our uh Shia Muslim sister who is
presenting and look what happened in
these moments inshallah. And I'm going
to come uh to inshallah Yamama, uh I
think it's Yamama Walasmae, who is a
Norwegian news anchor who absolutely
gives facts and grills a spokesman of uh
the Israeli uh
state uh of how many journalists they've
killed. And this is a video footage now
showing you the attack that just
happened while she was presenting. They
are keep attacking journalists. Why?
We'll find out in a minute inshallah.
Let's go to that footage inshallah,
brothers and sisters. radio and
television building.
This has just been in the last few
minutes. In fact, it happened as
we were speaking to Taher Asadi. Let's
just take a listen.
So, this was uh happening uh live on
Iranian state TV as the Israeli uh
strike So, the footage that you just
uh saw I guess I'll be honest with you.
Um subhanallah she was quite brave. She
just casually just, you know,
subhanallah she just walked off and you
can see people at the back chanting God
is the greatest.
Um uh which people tried to distort it
as if it's something
uh negative. It just means God is the
greatest subhanallah and that is what
you say in the moment of death that God
is the greatest. So, brothers and
sisters subhanallah um how many
journalists why do they keep attacking
journalists? You need to understand
something. Now, let's watch
interview with the Norwegian uh
journalist
uh Yamma who
questions and look how many journalists
they have killed. You would not believe
your eyes. Listen to this now.
Is there anything positive about this
country or everything is bad? Are we the
vicious are we the evil one? What? Yes,
you are. Yes, you are. You are the
vicious evil you guys are the most
vicious evil Zionists dirtbags that
could ever live in history and people
are going to know this is the beginning
of the end of Israel. People are going
to know those that country is going to
go back to the Palestinians and where
the Jews and the Christians and the
Muslims are going to live side by side
like they did for years. You Zionists
are the biggest anti-Semites. You are
the biggest enemies to Jews and Judaism
and you don't even believe you're
atheists.
I'm asking you a question. You are a
journalist covering Right now your prime
minister
has an arrest warrant against you. Okay.
By the way, for one of the crimes Okay.
Imagine for starving a population.
Yeah. Your heritage minister
Amichai Eliyahu said nuking Gaza was an
option and called for methods more
painful than death for Palestinians.
More journalists are killed in Gaza than
in both World Wars, Vietnam, the former
Yugoslavia, and Afghanistan combined
according to the Watson
Cost of War project.
As a former journalist and editor,
can you explain to us why Israel is
killing Palestinian journalists on a
mass scale? World War I, World War II,
former Yugoslavia,
and Afghanistan, and Vietnam. Just
imagine that, guys. Do you know why
they're attacking journalists? Do you
know why they're attacking the state TV
station? Because they know the power of
media. Because they have used it for
many years. Yes, because these Zionists
control, yes, they control Hollywood
directly. Directly. You go and look at
who the directors are. All of them, the
people at the top, they are all
Zionists. Everyone is waking up to this.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala talks about
these individuals in the Quran. Okay,
these Zionists, brothers and sisters,
Allah talks about them. Brothers and
sisters, they are attacking journalists.
And look through What is their
justification? Check this out, yeah. And
this is, by the way, uh BBC News, okay?
So, what did they say? What they said,
"Iranian broadcaster uh is being used
for military purposes," says IDF. You
can't make this stuff up. They bomb
hospitals, kill innocent people, they
say it's being used for military base,
etc. And if you look at it, they are the
only ones that are using them for human
shields. Because their infrastructures,
all of these military infrastructures
are what? In the middle of Tel Aviv, in
the middle, not on the outskirts. There,
they are using it. Every accusation is a
confession. What does it say? "We are
now hearing more about the strikes on
Iran's state broadcaster." The Israel
Defense Force, the IDF, says in a
statement that the Air Force targeted a
communication center that was being used
for military purposes by Iranian armed
forces.
You can't make this stuff up. The whole
of Iran,
the whole of Iran, and they want to use
a TV station.
You can't make this stuff up. This is
can't be justified. Massacring people.
Subhanallah. It goes on to say the
building was being used under the guise
of civilian activity, and that and that
is strike
and that is strike directly harmed the
military capabilities of Iranian armed
forces. Uh prior to the strike, the IDF
provided an effective advance warning to
the civil population, including phone
calls, and conducted the strike in
precise manner in order to mitigate harm
to civilians as far as possible. Aw,
they're going to melt our hearts.
Subhanallah. So, you can see guys,
Subhanallah, even
the BBC when they are talking about this
What is What is the title? Debris falls
on Iranian TV studio during live
broadcast as I mean guys, you can't make
this stuff up. They have dehumanized,
devalued any human life besides a
blond-haired, blue-eyed, white
individual, Caucasian. Anything besides
that is justified. That's the reason why
it took Piers Morgan so much longer to
come and condemn and come out here.
Subhanallah. As you can see, so the
reason why they are doing this brothers
and sisters is because they know they
understand the power of journalism they
are justifying that any means guys.
Subhanallah, that oh, there was a
military base. You can see the lies.
People don't buy it. Like Bassam uh
Yusuf called it out. You guys are liars.
Nobody is buying anymore. Your
arrogance, you think you are
untouchable. Zionists think that they
are They have this thing of God's chosen
people. They actually feel like they're
untouchable. They feel like nobody can
touch us. That's the reason why they're
making such blunders, recording
themselves committing genocide. They
actually think they're invincible. And
little do they know that this is the
beginning of the end of Israel and
Zionism. And the whole world is going to
know how dangerous you are. And you have
nuclear weapons. You are far more
dangerous to the whole world. And mark
my words.
Mark my words guys. Okay? I'm not
anyone's side here.
Mark my words guys.
If the state of Israel is in danger,
those news are going to be targeted to
America. Let me tell you one thing and
I'll end on this. Yes? What is one
nation? What is one group of people you
cannot criticize? Not Muslims and Islam.
You could People have criticized us for
years on end decades. Listen to this
American man. Can't you criticize? Who?
Who can't you criticize in America?
An easy way to know if you are
controlled
is there somebody or something that
you're not allowed to criticize? If you
lived in Nazi Germany, you couldn't
criticize the Nazi Party. If you lived
in the Soviet Union, you couldn't
criticize the Communist Party of Russia.
If you live in China right now, you
can't criticize the Chinese Communist
Party. If you live in North Korea, you
can't criticize Kim Jong-un. If you live
in America,
who can't you criticize? Who?
Who can't you criticize in America? The
Jewish lobby. Yes, on both sides. Right.
You're not allowed The fact that we're
having this discussion and we're on the
edge. Why are we on the edge? Because
we're touching the third rail. We're
breaking the taboo. You're not allowed
to discuss the power of the Israeli
lobby in America. That's proof right
there. They control America. Exactly.
That's what's called the United States
of Israel, Zionism. Brothers and
sisters, I'm going to keep you up to
date inshallah. And don't forget to
subscribe to the The Sean's channel,
Smile 2 Jannah inshallah, who has
amazing amazing updates and with amazing
facts inshallah. So, brothers and
sisters, till next time inshallah.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. I will inshallah be keeping
you up to date with what's going on cuz
it's very very important for us to
understand
what the different what is going on cuz
it has a direct impact on us as well.
So, as-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.